for nearly 30 years the neon museum has
been one of the most Vivid connections
to our past its signs or a trip back to
Vintage Las Vegas the only problem now
it has more history than space John
langler looks at the Museum's next steps
[Music]
the museum is at a state where we are
really looking at all of our
opportunities there really is nothing
else like it a dirt lot filled with
discarded signs part of History it's a
fabulous part of our history perhaps
elsewhere they'd be trash here it's art
it's not enough just to Simply see the
signs but we need to have some context
attached to them Aaron Berger is
executive director for the neon Museum
he says visitation is Relentless the
neon Boneyard overflowing bottom line
the museum needs room to illuminate
expansion is key to our survival Berger
says the Boneyard holds 175 signs right
now 75 are on display in the north
Gallery next door but more than 300 neon
artifacts are stashed in a warehouse
from my perspective and I think
certainly the perspective of our board
and staff that's not doing anybody any
good to have those sitting in storage
there seemed to be a solution a few
years ago the neon Museum said it would
expand across the street to the old Reed
Whipple building the only problem it was
entire terrible shape the plan was
abandoned now the museum is expanding
its expansion plans we are looking
forward to finding a site that allows us
to capitalize on what we have here
that's something that takes time and
takes planning so we're at the very
beginning stages of of that right now
Berger hopes a larger Museum will
include more than just signs how they
work how to make them it's just a matter
of time and money to get more lights on
we do have an audience that wants more
than what we are currently able to offer
John langler 8 News Now